The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I just started
talking a little bit last time
about viewing L2, namely this
set of functions that are
square integrable as
a vector space.
And I want to reveal a
little bit about why
we want to do that.
Because after spending so long
worrying about all these
questions of measurability and
all that, you must wonder, why
do we want to look at it
a different way now.
Well, a part of it is we want
to be able to look at
orthogonal expansions
geometrically.
In other words, we would
like to be able to
draw pictures of them.
You can draw pictures of a
function, but you're drawing a
picture of one function.
And you can't draw anything
about the relationship between
different functions, except
by drawing the
two different functions.
You get all the detail
there, and you can't
abstract it at all.
So somehow we want to start
to abstract some of this
information.
And we want to be able to draw
pictures which look more like
vector pictures than
like functions.
And you'll see why that becomes
important in a while.
The other thing is, when you
draw a function as a function
of time, the only thing you see
it how it behaves in time.
When you take the Fourier
transform and you draw it in
frequency, the only thing
you see is how
it behaves in frequency.
And, again, you don't see what
the relationship is between
different functions.
So you lose all of that.
When you take this signal space
viewpoint, what you're
trying to do there is to not
stress time or frequency so
much, but more to look
at the relationship
between different functions.
Why do we want to do that?
Well, because as soon as we
start looking at noise and
things like that, we want to
be able to tell something
about how distinguishable
different functions are from
each other.
So the critical question there
you want to ask, when you ask
how different functions are,
is how do you look at two
functions both at
the same time.
So, again, that's --
all of this is coming back
to the same thing.
So we want to be able to draw
pictures of functions which
show how functions are related,
rather than show all
the individual detail
of function.
Finally, what we'll see at the
end of today that it gives us
a lot of capability for
understanding much, much
better what's going on when
we look at conversions of
orthogonal series.
This is something we haven't had
any way to look at before
we talked about the Fourier
series, the discrete time
Fourier transform, and
things like this.
But we haven't been able to
really say something general.
Which, again, is what
we want to do now.
I'm going to go very quickly
through these axioms of a
vector space.
Most of you have seen
them before.
Those of you who haven't seen
axiomatic treatments of
various things in mathematics
are going to be
puzzled by it anyway.
And you're going to have to sit
at home or somewhere on
your own and puzzle this out.
But I just wanted to put them
up so I could start to say
what it is that we're trying
to do with these axioms.
What we're trying to do is to
say everything we know about
n-tuples, which we've been
using all of our lives.
All of these tricks that we use,
most of them we can use
to deal with functions also.
The pictures, we can use.
All of the ideas about
dimension, all of the ideas
about expansions.
All of this stuff becomes
useful again.
But, there are a lot of things
that are true about functions
that aren't true
about vectors.
There are lots of things which
are true about n-dimensional
vectors that aren't true
about functions.
And you want to be able to go
back to these axioms when you
have to, and say, well, is this
property we're looking at
something which is a consequence
of the axioms.
Namely, is this an inherent
property of vector spaces, or
is it in fact something else
which is just because of the
particular kind of thing
we're looking at.
So, vector spaces.
Important thing is, there's
an addition operation.
You can add any two vectors.
You can't multiply
them, by the way.
You can only add them.
You can multiply by scalars,
which we'll talk about in the
next slide.
But you can only add the
vectors themselves.
And the addition is commutative,
just like
ordinary addition of real
numbers or complex numbers is.
It's associative, which says
v, u plus w in parentheses.
Now, you see why we're doing
this is, we've said by
definition that for any two
vectors, u and w, there's
another vector, which
is called u plus w.
In other words, this axiomatic
system says, whenever you add
two vectors you have
to get a vector.
There's no way around that.
So u plus w has to
be a vector.
And that says that v plus u
plus w has to be a vector.
Associativity says that you
get the same vector if you
look at it the other way,
if first adding v and u
and then adding w.
So, anything what you call
a vector space has
to have this property.
Of course, the real numbers
have this property.
The complex numbers have
this property.
All the n-tuples you
deal with all the
time have this property.
Functions have this property.
Sequences, infinite length
sequences have this property,
so there's no big
deal about it.
But that is one of the axioms.
There's a unique vector 0, such
that when you add 0 to a
vector, you get the
same vector again.
Now, this is not the 0 in
the real number system.
It's not the 0 in a complex
number system.
In terms of vectors, if you're
thinking of n-tuples, this is
the n-tuple which is all 0's.
In terms of other vectors,
spaces, it
might be other things.
Like, in terms of functions, 0
means the function which is 0
everywhere.
And finally, there's the unique
vector minus v, which
has the property that v plus
minus v -- in other words, v
minus v -- is equal to 0.
And in a sense that defines
subtraction as well as addition.
So we have addition and
subtraction, but we don't have
multiplication.
And there's scalar
Which means you can multiply
a vector by a scalar.
And the vector spaces we're
looking at here only have two
kinds of scalars.
One is real scalars and the
other is complex scalars.
The two are quite different,
as you know.
And so when we're talking about
a vector space we have
to say what the scalar field is
that we're talking about.
So, for every vector.
And also for every scalar,
there's another vector which
is the scalar times
the vector.
Which means, you have scalar
multiplication.
You can multiply vectors by
scalars in terms of n-tuples.
When you're multiplying a scalar
by an n-tuple, you just
multiply every component
by that scalar.
When you take the scalar 1, and
in a field there's always
an element 1, there's
always an element 0.
When you take the element 1,
and you multiply it by a
vector, you got the
same vector.
Which, of course, is what you
would expect if you were
looking at functions.
You multiply a function.
For every t you multiply it by
1, and you get the same thing
back again.
For an n-tuple, you multiply
every component by 1, you get
the same thing back again.
So that's --
well, it's just another axiom.
Then we have these distributive
laws.
And I won't read them
out to you, they're
just what they say.
I want to talk about them in
a second a little bit.
And as we said, the simplistic
example of a vector space, and
the one you've been using for
years, partly because it saves
you a lot of notation.
Incidentally, one of the reasons
I didn't list for
talking about L2 as a vector
space is, it saves you a lot
of writing.
Also, just like when you're
talking about n-tuples it
saves you writing.
It's a nice, convenient
notational device.
I don't think any part of
mathematics becomes popular
with everyone, unless it saves
notation as well as well as
simplifying things.
So we have these n-tuples, which
is what we mean by r sub
n or c sub n.
In other words, when I talk
about r sub n, I don't mean
just a vector space
of dimension n.
I haven't even defined
dimension yet.
And when you talk in this
generality, you have to think
a little bit about
what it means.
So we're just talking about
n-tuples now. r sub n is
n-tuples of real numbers.
c sub n is
n-tuples of complex numbers.
Addition and scalar
multiplication are component
by component, which
we just said.
In other words, w equals u plus
v means this, for all i.
Scalar multiplication
means this.
The unit vector, e sub i, is a
1 in the i'th position, a 0
everywhere else.
And what that means is that
any vector v which is an
n-tuple, n rn or n cn, can
also be expressed as the
equals summation of these
coefficients,
times these unit factors.
That looks like we're giving up
the simple notation we have
and going to more complex
notation.
This is a very useful
idea here.
That you can take even something
as simple as
n-tuples and express every
vector as a sum of these
simple vectors.
And when you start drawing
pictures, you start to see why
this makes sense.
I'm going to do this
on the next slide.
So let's do it.
And on the slide here, what I've
done is to draw a diagram
which is one you've seen
many times, I'm sure.
Except for the particular
things on it.
Of two-dimensional space, where
you take a 2-tuple and
you think of the first element
in the 2-tuple, v1, a being
the horizontal axis.
The second element, v2, as
being the vertical axis.
And then you can draw any
2-tuple by going over v1 and
then up v2, which is what you've
done all your lives.
The reason I'm drawing this is
to show you that you can take
any two vectors.
First vector, v. Second
vector, u.
One thing that --
I'm sure you all traditionally
do is you view a
vector in two ways.
One, you view it as a point
in two-dimensional space.
And the other is you view it as
a line from 0 up to v. And
when you put a little arrow on
it, it looks like a vector,
and we call it a vector.
So it must be a vector, OK?
So either the point or the
line represents a vector.
Here's another vector, u.
I can take the difference
between two vectors, u minus
v, just by drawing a line
from v up to u.
And thinking of that
as a vector also.
So this vector really means a
vector starting here, going
parallel to this, up to this
point, which is what w is.
But it's very convenient to draw
it this way, which lets
you know what's going on.
Namely, you represent u as
the sum of v plus w.
Or you represent w as a
difference between u and v.
And all of this is trivial.
I just want to say it explicitly
so you start to see
what the connection is between
these axioms, which if I don't
talk about them a little bit,
I'm sure you're just going to
blow them off and decide, eh, I
know all of that, I can look
at things in two dimensions
and I don't have to think
about them at all.
And then, in a few days, when
we're doing the same thing for
functions, you're suddenly going
to become very confused.
So you ought to think about
it in these simple terms.
Now, when I take a scalar
multiple of the vector, in
terms of these diagrams, what
we're doing is taking
something on this
same line here.
I can take scalar multiples
which go all the way up here,
all the way down there.
I can take scalar multiples
of u which go up here.
And down here.
The interesting thing here is
when I scale v down by alpha
and I scale u down by alpha, I
can also scale w down by alpha
and I connect it just like that,
from alpha v to alpha u.
Which axiom is that?
I mean, this is the
canonic example of
one of those axioms.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Distributed.
PROFESSOR: Distributed, good.
This is saying that alpha times
the quantity u minus v
is equal to alpha u minus alpha
v. That's so trivial
that it's hard to see it, but
that's what it's saying.
So that the distributive law
really says the triangles
maintain their shape.
Maybe it's easier to just
say distributive
law, I don't know.
So, for the space of L2 complex
functions, we're going
to define u plus v as w,
where w of t equals u
of t plus v of t.
Now, I've done a bunch of
things here all at once.
One of them is to say what we
used to call a function, u of
t, we're now referring to with
a single letter, boldface u.
What's the advantage of that?
Well, one advantage of it is
when you talk about a function
as u of t, you're really
talking about
two different things.
One, you're talking about the
value of the function at a
particular argument, t.
And the other is,
you're talking
about the whole function.
I mean, sometimes you
want to say a
function has some property.
A function is L2.
Well, u of t at a particular
t is just a number.
It's not a function.
So this gives us a nice way
of distinguishing between
functions and between the
value of functions for
particular arguments.
So that's one more notational
advantage you get by talking
about vectors here.
We're going to define the sum
of two functions just as the
point y sum.
In other words, these
two functions are
defined at each t.
w defined at a t is the
sum of this and that.
The scalar multiplication is
just defined by, at every t, u
of t is equal to alpha
times v of t.
Just what you'd expect.
There's nothing strange here.
I just want to be explicit in
saying how everything follows
from these axioms here.
And I won't say all
of it because
there's too much of it.
With this addition and scalar
multiplication, L2, the set of
finite energy measurable
functions is in fact the
complex vector space.
And it's trivial to go back
and check through all the
axioms with what we said
here, and I'm not
going to do it now.
There's only one of those
axioms which is a bit
questionable.
And that is, when you add up two
functions which are square
integrable, is the sum going to
be square integrable also.
Well, you nod and say yes, but
it's worthwhile proving it
once in your lives.
So the question is, is this
function here less than
infinity if the integral of u of
t squared and the integral
of v of t squared are
both integrable.
Well, it's a useful inequality,
which looks like a
very weak inequality but it,
in fact, is not weak.
It says that u of
t plus v of t.
This is just at a particular
value of t.
So this is just an inequality
for real
numbers and complex numbers.
It says that this u of t plus
v of t, quantity squared,
magnitude squared, is less than
or equal to 2 times u of
t squared plus 2 times
v of t squared.
You wonder, at first, what's
the 2 doing in there.
But then think of making
v of t equal to u of t.
You have 2 times u of t
squared, which is 4
times u of t squared.
Well, that's what you need
here to make this true.
So, in that example
this inequality is
satisfied with equality.
To verify the inequality
in general, you just
multiply this out.
It's u of t squared plus v of t
squared plus two cross-terms
and it all works.
This vector space here is not
quite the vector space we want
to talk about.
But let's put off that question
for a while and we'll
come to it later.
We will come up with a vector
space which is just slightly
different than that.
The main thing you can do with
vector spaces is talk about
their dimension.
Well, there are a lot of other
things you can do, but this is
one of the main things
we can do.
And it's an important thing
which we have to talk about
before going into inner product
spaces, which is what
we're really interested in.
So we need a bunch of
definitions here.
All of this, I'm sure is
familiar to most of you.
For those of you that it's not
familiar to, you just have to
spend a little longer with it.
There's not a whole
lot involved here.
If you have a set of vectors,
which are in a vector space,
you say that they span the
vector space if in fact every
vector in this vector
space is a linear
combination of those vectors.
In other words, any vector, u,
can be made up as some sum of
alpha i times v sub i.
Now, notice we've gone a long
way here beyond those axioms.
Because we're talking about
scalar multiplications.
And then we're talking about
a sum of a lot of scalar
multiplications.
Each scalar multiplication
is a vector.
The sum of a bunch of vectors,
by the associative law is, in
fact, another vector.
So every one of these
sums is a vector.
And by definition, a set of
vectors spans a vector space
if every vector can be
represented as some linear
combination of them.
In
other words, there isn't
something outside of here
sitting there waiting to
be discovered later.
You really understand everything
that's there.
And we say that v is finite
dimensional if it is spanned
by a finite set of vectors.
So that's another definition.
That's what you mean by
finite dimensional.
You have to be able to find a
finite set of vectors such
that linear combinations of
those vectors gives you
everything.
It doesn't mean you have a
finite set of vectors.
You have an infinite set of
vectors because you have an
infinite set of scalars.
In fact, you'd have an
uncountably infinite set of
vectors because of
these scalars.
Second definition.
The vector v1 to vn are linearly
independent -- and
this is a mouthful -- if u
equals the sum of alpha sub i
v sub i equals 0, only
for alpha sub i equal
to 0 for each i.
In other words, you can't take
any linear combination of the
v sub i's and get 0 unless that
linear combination is
using all 0's.
You can't, in any non-trivial
way, add up a bunch of
vectors and get 0.
To put it another way, none of
these basis vectors is a
linear combination
of the others.
That's usually a more convenient
way to put it.
Although it takes
more writing.
Now, we say that a set of
vectors are a basis for v if
they're both linearly
independent and if they span
v. When we first talked about
spanning, we didn't say
anything about these vectors
being linearly independent, so
we might have had many more
of them than we needed.
Now, when we're talking about a
basis, we restrict ourselves
to just the set we need
to span the space.
And then the theorem, which I'm
not going to prove, but
it's standard Theorem One of
any linear algebra book --
well, it's probably Theorem One,
Two, Three and Four all
put together -- but anyway, if
it says if v1 and v sub n span
v, then a subset of these
vectors is the basis of b.
In other words, if you have a
set of vectors which span a
space, you can find the basis by
systematically eliminating
vectors which are linear
combinations of the others,
until you get to a point where
you can't do that any further.
So this theorem has an algorithm
tied into it.
Given any set of vectors which
span a space, you can find the
basis from it by perhaps
throwing out
some of those vectors.
The next part of it is, if v is
a finite dimensional space,
then every basis has
the same size.
This, in fact, is a thing which
takes a little bit of
work proving it.
And, also, any linearly
independent set, v1 to v sub
n, is part of the basis.
In other words, here's another
algorithm you can use.
You have this big, finite
dimensional space.
You have a few vectors which
are linearly independent.
You can build a basis starting
with these, and you just
experiment.
You experiment to find new
vectors, which are not linear
combinations of that set.
As soon as you find one, you
add it to the basis.
You keep on going.
And the theorem says, by
time you get to n of
them, you're done.
So that, in a sense, spanning
sets are too big.
Linearly independent
sets are too small.
And what you want to do is add
the linearly independent sets,
shrink the spanning sets, and
come up with a bases.
And all bases have the same
number of vectors.
There many different bases you
come up with, but they all
have the same number
of vectors.
Not going to talk at all about
infinite dimensional spaces
until the last slide today.
Because the only way I know
to understand infinite
dimensional vector spaces is by
thinking of them, in some
sort of limiting way, as finite
dimensional spaces.
And I think that's the only
way you can do it.
A vector space in itself has
no sense of distance
or angles in it.
When I drew that picture before
for you -- let me put
it up again --
it almost looked like
there was some sense
of distance in here.
Because when we took scalar
multiples, we scaled these
things down.
When I took these triangles, we
scaled down the triangle,
and the triangle
was maintained.
But, in fact, I could do this
just as well if I took v and
moved it down here almost down
on this axis, and if I took u
and moved that almost
down on the axis.
I have the same picture, the
same kind of distributive law.
And everything else.
You can't --
I mean, one of the troubles with
n-dimensional space, to
study what a vector space is
about, is it's very hard to
think of n-tuples without
thinking of distance.
And without thinking of things
being orthogonal to each
other, and of all
of these things.
None of that is talked about at
all in any of these axioms.
And, in fact, you need some new
axioms to be able to talk
about ideas of distance, or
angle, or any of these things.
And that's what we
want to add here.
So we need some new axioms.
And what we need is a new
operation on the vector space,
before the only -- the only
operations we have are
addition and scalar
multiplication.
So that vector spaces
are really
incredibly simple animals.
There's very little you
can do with them.
And this added thing is called
an inner product.
An inner product is
a scalar valued
function of two vectors.
And it's represented by
these little brackets.
And the axioms that these inner
products have to satisfy
is, if you're dealing with
a complex vector space.
In other words, where the
scalars are complex numbers,
then this inner product, when
you switch it around, you have
Hermitian symmetry.
Which means that this inner
product is equal to u v
complex conjugate.
We've already seen that
sort of thing in
taking Fourier series.
And the fact that when you're
dealing with complex numbers,
symmetry doesn't usually hold,
and you usually need some kind
of Hermitian symmetry in most
of the things you do.
The next axiom is something
called bilinearity.
It says that if you take a
vector which is alpha times a
vector v, plus beta times a
vector u, take the inner
product of that with w, it
splits up as alpha times v w
plus beta times u w.
How about if I do it
the other way?
See if you understand what I'm
talking about at all here.
Suppose we take w alpha u plus
beta v. What's that equal to?
Well, it's equal to alpha
something w u plus beta w v.
Except that's wrong, It's right
for real vector spaces,
it's wrong for complex
vector spaces.
What am I missing here?
I need complex conjugates here
and complex conjugates here.
I wanted to talk about that,
because when you're dealing
with inner products, I don't
know whether you're like me,
but every time I start dealing
with inner products and I get
in a hurry writing things down,
I forgot to put those
damn complex conjugates
in them.
And, just be careful.
Because you need them.
At least go back after you're
all done and put the complex
conjugates in.
If you're dealing with real
vectors, of course you don't
need to worry about
any of that.
And all the pictures you draw
are always of real vectors.
Think of trying to draw
this picture.
This is the simplest picture
you can draw.
Of two-dimensional vectors.
This is really a picture of a
vector space of dimension two,
for real vectors.
What happens if you try to
draw a picture of complex
two-dimensional vector space?
Well, it becomes very
difficult to do.
Because you're really talking
about the real part of, if
you're dealing with a basis
which consists of two complex
vectors, then instead of v1, you
need a real part of v1 and
imaginary part of v1.
Instead of v2, you need
real part of v2 and
imaginary part of v2.
And you can always draw this
in four dimensions.
And I even have trouble drawing
in three dimensions,
because somehow my pen doesn't
make marks in three
dimensions.
And in four dimensions,
I'm a blinking 12.
And have no idea
of what to do.
So you have to remember this.
If you're dealing with rn or cn,
almost always you define
the inner product of v and u as
the sum of the components
with the second component
complex conjugated.
This is just a standard thing
that we do all the time.
When we do this, and we use
unit vectors, the inner
product of v with the i'th unit
vector is just v sub i.
That's what this formula says.
Because e sub i is this vector
u, in which there's a 1 only
in the i'th position, and
a 0 everywhere else.
So v e i is always the v i,
and e i v is always v i
complex conjugate.
Again, this Hermitian nonsense
that comes up to
plague us all the time.
And from that, if you make v
equal to e sub j or e sub i,
you get the inner product of two
of these basis vectors is
equal to 0 for i unequal to j.
In other words, the standard way
of drawing pictures when
you make it into an inner
product space, those unit
vectors become orthonormal.
Because that's the way you
like to draw things.
You like to draw one
here and one there.
And that's what we mean by
perpendicular, which the
two-dimensional or
three-dimensional word for
orthogonal.
So we have a couple
of definitions.
The inner product of v with
itself is called inner product
v squared, which is called the
squared norm of the vector.
The squared norm has to be
non-negative, by axiom.
It has to be greater than 0,
unless this vector, v, is in
fact a 0 vector.
And the length is
just the square
root of the norm squared.
In other words, the length and
the norm are the same thing.
The norm of a vector is the
length of the vector.
I've always called it the
length, but a lot of people
like to call it the norm.
v and u are orthogonal if the
inner product of v and u is
equal to 0.
How did I get that?
I defined it that why.
Everybody defines it that way.
That's what you mean
by orthogonality.
Now we have to go back and see
if it makes any sense in terms
of these nice simple diagrams.
But first I'm going to do
something called the
one-dimensional projection
theorem.
Which is something you all know
but you probably have
never thought about.
And what it says is, if you have
to vectors, v and u, you
can always break v up
into two parts.
One of which is on the
same line with u.
In other words, is
colinear with u.
I'm drawing a picture here for
real spaces, but when I say
colinear, when I'm dealing with
complex spaces, I mean
it's u times some scalar,
which could be complex.
So it's somewhere
on this line.
And the other part is
perpendicular to this line.
And this theorem says in any
old inner product space at
all, no matter how many
dimensions you have, infinite
dimensional, finite dimensional,
anything, if it's
an inner product space on either
the scalars r or the
scalars c, you can always take
any old two vectors at all.
And you can break one vector up
into a part that's colinear
with the other, and another
part which is orthogonal.
And you can always draw
a picture of it.
If you don't mind just drawing
the picture for real vectors
instead of complex vectors.
This is an important idea.
Because what we're going to use
it for in a while, is to
be able to talk about functions
which are these
incredibly complicated
objects.
And we're going to talk about
two different functions.
And we want to be able to draw
a picture in which those two
functions are represented
just as points in a
two-dimensional picture.
And we're going to do that by
saying, OK, I take one of
those functions.
And I can represent it as partly
being colinear with
this other function.
And partly being orthogonal
to the other function.
Which says, you can forget about
all of these functions
which extend to infinity, in
time extend to infinity, in
frequency and everything else.
And, so long as you're only
interested in some small set
of functions, you can just deal
with them as a finite
dimensional vector space.
You can get rid of all the mess,
and just think of them
in this very simple sense.
That's really why this vector
space idea, which is called
signal space, is so popular
among engineers.
It lets than get rid of all the
mess and think in terms of
very, very simple things.
So let's see why this
complicated
theorem is in fact true.
Let me state the
theorem first.
It says for any inner products
space, v. And any vectors, u
and v in v, with u
unequal to 0 --
I hope I said that in the notes
-- the vector v can be
broken up into a colinear term
plus an orthogonal term, where
the colinear term is equal
to a scalar times u.
That's what we mean
by colinear.
That's just the definition
of colinear.
And the other vector
is orthogonal to u.
And alpha is uniquely given by
the inner product v u divided
by the norm squared of u.
Now, there's one thing
ugly about this.
You see that norm squared, you
say, what is that doing there.
It just looks like it's making
the formula complicated.
Forgot about that for
the time being.
We will get into it in a minute
and explain why we have
that problem.
But, for the moment, let's
just prove this
and see what it says.
So what we're going to do is
say, well, if I don't look at
what the theorem is saying, what
I'd like to do is look at
some generic element which is
a scalar multiple times u.
So I'll say, OK let v parallel
to u be alpha times u.
I don't know what alpha is yet,
but alpha's going to be
whatever it has to be.
We're going to choose alpha so
that this other vector, v
minus v u, is a thing we're
calling v perp.
So that that, the inner product
of that and u, is
equal to 0.
So what I'm trying to do
is to find a vector --
strategy here, is to take any
old vector along this line and
try to choose the scalar alpha
in such a way that the
difference between this point
and this point is orthogonal
to this line.
That's why I started out
with alpha unknown.
Alpha unknown just
says we have any
point along this line.
Now I'm going to find out
what alpha has to be.
I hope I will find out that it
has to be only one thing, and
it's uniquely chosen.
And that's what we're
going to find.
So v minus this projection
term, this is called a
projection of v on u, is equal
to v u minus a projection
inner product with u.
So it's equal to this
difference here.
This is equal to the
inner product.
Since we have chosen this term
to be alpha times u, we can
bring the alpha out.
So it's alpha times the inner
product of u with itself.
That's the norm squared
of alpha.
So this is inner product of v
and u minus alpha times the
norm squared.
This is 0 if and only if you
set this equal to 0.
And the only value alpha can
have to make this 0 is the
inner product of v and u divided
by the norm squared.
So I would think that if I ask
you to prove this without
knowing the projection theorem,
I would hope that if
you weren't afraid of it or
something, and you just sat
down and tried to do it,
you would all do it in
about half an hour.
It would probably take most of
you longer than that, because
everybody gets screwed up in the
notation when they first
try to do this.
But, in fact, this is not
a complicated thing.
This is not rocket science.
Now.
What is this norm squared
doing here?
The thing we have just proven is
that with any two vectors v
and u, the projection of v on
u, namely that vector, there
which has the property that v
minus v u is perpendicular to
u, we showed, is this inner
product divided by the norm
squared times u.
Now, let me break up
this norm squared.
Which is just some
positive number.
It's a positive real number.
Into the length times
the length.
Namely, the norm u is just
some real number.
And write it this way, as the
inner product of v with u
divided by the length of
u times u divided by
the length of u.
Now, what is the vector u
divided by the length of u?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: It's the same
direction of u, but
it has length 1.
In other words, this is the
normalized form of u.
And I have the normalized
form of u in here also.
So what this is saying is that
this projection is also equal
to the projection of v on the
normalized form of u, times
the normalized form of u.
Which says that it doesn't make
any difference what the
length of u is.
This projection is a function
only of the direction of u.
I mean, this is obvious from
the picture, isn't it?
But again, since we can't draw
pictures for complex valued
things, it's nice to be able
to see it analytically.
If I shorten u, or lengthen u,
this projection is still going
to be exactly the same thing.
And that's what the norm squared
of u is doing here.
The norm squared of u is simply
sitting there so it
does this normalization
function for us.
It makes this projection equal
to the inner product of v with
the normalized form
of u, times the
normalized vector for u.
The Pythagorean theorem, which
doesn't follow from this, it's
something else, but it's simple
-- in fact, we can do
it right away -- it says if v
and u are orthogonal, then the
norm squared of u plus
v is equal to u
squared plus v squared.
I mean, this is something
you use
geometrically all the time.
And you're familiar with this.
And the argument is, you just
break this up into the norm
squared of u plus the norm
squared of v, plus the two
cross-products, the inner
product of u times the inner
product of u with v, which is 0,
and the inner product of v
with u, which is 0.
So the two cross-terms
go away and you're
left with just this.
And for any v and u, the Schwarz
inequality says that
the inner product, the magnitude
of the inner product
of v and u, is less than or
equal to the length of v times
the length of u.
The Schwarz inequality is
probably -- well, I'm not sure
that it's probably, but it's
perhaps the most used
inequality in mathematics.
Any time you use vectors, you
use this all the time.
And it's extremely useful.
I'm not going to prove it here
because it's in the notes.
It's a two-step proof from
what we've done.
And the trouble is watching
two-step proofs in class.
At a certain point you
saturate on them.
And I have more important things
I want to do later
today, so I don't want you
to saturate on this.
You can read this at
your leisure and
see why this is true.
I did want to say something
about it, though.
If you divide the left side by
the right side, you can write
this as the magnitude of the
inner product of the
normalized form of v with the
normalized form of u.
If we're talking about real
vector space, this in fact is
the cosine of the angle
between v and u.
It's less than or equal to 1.
So for real two-dimensional
vectors, the fact that the
cosine is less than or equal to
1 is really equivalent to
the Schwarz inequality.
And this is the appropriate
generalization for any old
vectors at all.
And the notes would say more
about that if that went a
little too quickly.
OK, the inner product space of
interest to us is this thing
we've called signal space.
Namely, it's a space of
functions which are measurable
n square integrals.
In other words, finite value
when you take the square and
integrate it.
And we want to be able to talk
about the set of either real
or complex L2 functions.
So, either one of them, we're
going to define the inner
product in the same
way for each.
It really is the only natural
way to define an
inner product here.
And you'll see this more later
as we start doing other things
with these inner products.
But just like what when you're
dealing with n-tuples, there's
only one sensible way to define
an inner product.
You can define inner products
in other ways.
But it's just a little
bizarre to do so.
And here it's a little
bizarre also.
There's a big technical
problem here.
And if you look at, it can
anybody spot what it -- no,
no, of course you can't spot
what it is unless you've read
the notes and you
know what it is.
One of the axioms of an inner
product space is that the only
vector in the space which has an
inner product with itself,
a squared norm equal to zero
is the zero vector.
Now, we have all these crazy
vector we've been talking
about, which are zero, except
on a set of measures zero.
In other words, vectors'
functions which have zero
energy but just pop up at
various isolated points and
have values there.
Which we really can't get rid
of if we view a function as
something which is defined
at every value of t.
You have to accept those things
as part of what you're
dealing with.
As soon as you started
integrating things, those
things all disappear.
But the trouble is, those
functions, which are zero
almost everywhere,
are not zero.
They're only zero almost
everywhere.
They're zero for all engineering
purposes.
But they're not zero, they're
only zero almost everywhere.
Well, if you define the inner
product in this way and you
want to satisfy the axioms of an
inner product space, you're
out of luck.
There's no way you can
do it, because this
axiom just gets violated.
So what do you do?
Well, you do what we've
been doing all along.
We've been sort of squinting a
little bit and saying, well,
really, these functions of
measure 0 are really 0 for all
practical purposes.
Mathematically, what we have
to say is, we want to talk
about an equivalence
class of functions.
And two functions are in the
same equivalence class if
their difference has 0 energy.
Which is equivalent to saying
their difference is zero
almost everywhere.
It's one of these bizarre
functions which just jumps up
at isolated points and doesn't
do anything else.
Not impulses at isolated points,
just non-zero at
isolated points.
Impulses are not really
functions at all.
So we're talking about things
that are functions, but
they're these bizarre functions
which we talked
about and we've said they're
unimportant.
So, but they are there.
So the solution is to associate
vectors with
equivalence classes.
And d of t and u of t are
equivalent if the v of t minus
u of t is zero almost
everywhere.
In other words, when we talk
about a vector, u, what we're
talking about is an
equivalence class of functions.
It's the equivalence class of
functions for which two
functions are in the same
equivalence class if they
differ only on a set
of measure zero.
In other words, these are the
things that gave us trouble
when we were talking about
Fourier transforms.
These are the things that gave
us trouble when we were
talking about Fourier series.
When you take anything in the
same equivalence class,
time-limited functions, and
you form a Fourier series,
what happens?
All of the things in the same
equivalence class have the
same Fourier coefficients.
But when you go back from the
Fourier series coefficients
back to the function, then you
might go back in a bunch of
different ways.
So, we started using this limit
in the mean notation and
all of that stuff.
And what we're doing here now
is, for these vectors, we're
just saying, let's represent
a vector as this whole
equivalence class.
While we're talking about
vectors, we're almost always
interested in orthogonal
expansions.
And when we're interested in
orthogonal expansions, the
coefficients in the orthogonal
expansions are found as
integrals with the function.
And the integrals with different
functions in the
same equivalence class
are identical.
In other words, any two
functions in the same
equivalence class have the
same coefficients in any
orthogonal expansion.
So if you talk only about the
orthogonal expansion, and
leave out these detailed notions
of what the function
is doing at individual times,
then you don't have to worry
about equivalence classes.
In other words, when you --
I'm going to say this again more
carefully later, but let
me try to say it now a
little bit crudely.
One of the things we're
interested in doing this
taking this class of functions,
mapping each
function into a set of
coefficients, where the set of
coefficients are the
coefficients in some
particular orthogonal expansion
that we're using.
Namely, that's the whole way
that we're using to get from
waveforms to sequences.
It's the whole --
it's the entire thing we're
doing when we start out on a
channel with a sequence of
binary digits and then a
sequence of symbols.
And we modulate it
into a waveform.
Again, it's the mapping from
sequence to waveform.
Now, the important thing here
about these equivalence
classes is, you can't tell
any of the members of the
equivalence class apart within
the sequence that we're
dealing with.
Everything we're interested
in has to
do with these sequences.
I mean, if we could we'd just
ignore the waveforms
altogether.
Because all the processing that
we do is with sequences.
So the only reason we have these
equivalence classes is
because we need them to really
define what the functions are.
So, we will come back
to that later.
Boy, I think I'm going
to get done today.
That's surprising.
The next idea that
we want to talk
about is vector subspaces.
Again, that's an idea you've
probably heard of,
for the most part.
A subspace of a vector space
is a subset of the vector
space such that that subspace
is a vector
space in its own right.
An equivalent definition is,
for all vectors u and v, in
the subspace alpha
times u plus beta
times v is in s also.
In other words, a subspace is
something which you can't get
out of by linear combinations.
If I take one of these diagrams
back here that I keep
looking at --
I'll use this one.
If I want to form a subspace of
this subspace, if I want to
form a subspace of this
two-dimensional vector space
here, one of the subspaces
includes
u, but not v, perhaps.
Now, if I want to make a
one-dimensional subspace
including u, what is
that subspace?
It's just all the
scalars times u.
In other words, it's this line
that goes through the origin
and through that vector, u.
And a subspace has to include
the whole line.
That's what we're saying.
It's all scalar multiples
of u.
If I want a subspace that
includes u and v, where u and
v are just arbitrary vectors
I've chosen out of my hat,
then I have this two-dimensional
subspace,
which is what I've drawn here.
In other words, this
idea is something
we've been using already.
It's just that we didn't need
to be explicit about it.
The subspace which includes
u and v --
well, a subspace which includes
u and v, is the
subspace of all linear
combinations of u and v. And
nothing else.
So, it's all vectors
along here.
It's all vectors along here.
And you fill it all in with
anything here added to
anything here.
So you get this two-dimensional
space.
Is 0 always in a subspace?
Of course it is.
I mean, you multiply
any vector by 0 and
you get the 0 vector.
So you sort of get
it as a linear --
what more can I say?
If we have a vector space which
is an inner product
space; in other words, if we
add this inner product
definition to our vector space,
and I take a subspace
of it, that can be defined as
an inner product space also,
with the same definition
of inner
product that I had before.
Because I can't get out of it
by linear combinations, and
the inner product is defined for
every pair of vectors in
that space.
So we still have a nice,
well-defined vector space,
which is an inner product space,
and which is a subspace
of the space we started with.
Everything I do from now on, I'm
going to assume that v is
an inner product space.
And want to look at how
we normalize vectors.
We've already talked
about that.
If I have a vector in this
vector space that's
normalized, if its
norm equals 1.
We already decided how to
normalize a vector.
We took an arbitrary vector,
u, divided by its norm.
And as soon as we divide by
its norm, that vector, v,
divided by the norm of v, the
norm of that is just 1.
So the projection, what the
projection theorem says, and
all I need here is a
one-dimensional projection
theorem, it says that v, in the
direction of this vector
phi, is equal to the
inner product of u
with phi times phi.
That's what we said.
As soon as we normalized these
vectors, that ugly denominator
here disappears.
Because the norm of
phi is equal to --
because the norm
is equal to 1.
So, an orthonormal set of
vectors is a set such that
each pair of vectors is
orthogonal to each other, and
where each vector
is normalized.
In other words, it has norm
squared equal to 1.
So, the inner product of these
vectors is just delta sub j k.
If I have an orthogonal set, v
sub j, say, then phi sub j is
an orthonormal set just by
taking each of these vectors
and normalizing it.
In other words, it's no big deal
to take an orthogonal set
of functions and turn
them into an
orthonormal set of functions.
The Fourier series was natural
to define that, and most
people define it, in such a way
that it's not orthonormal.
Because we're defining it over
some interval of time, t, that
has a norm squared of t and,
therefore, you have to divide
by square root of t
to normalize it.
If you want to put everything
in a common framework, it's
nice to deal with orthonormal
series.
And therefore, that's what we're
going to be stressing
from now on.
So I want to go on so the
real projection theorem.
Actually, there are three
projection theorems.
There's the one-dimensional
projection theorem.
There's the n-dimensional
projection theorem, which is
what this is.
And then there's an
infinite-dimensional
projection theorem, which is
not general for all inner
product spaces, but is certainly
general for L2.
So I'm going to assume that
phi 1 to phi sub n is an
orthonormal basis for an
n-dimensional subspace, s,
which is a subspace of v. How
do I know there is such an
orthonormal basis?
Well, I don't know that yet, and
I'm going to come back to
that later.
But for the time being, I'm just
going to assume that as
part of the theorem.
Assume I have some particular
subspace which has the
property that it has an
orthonormal basis.
So this is an orthonormal basis
for this n-dimensional
subspace, s and v. For each
vector in v, s now is some
small subspace.
v is a big subspace
out around s.
What I want to do now is, I want
to take some vector in
the big subspace.
I want to project it
onto the subspace.
By projecting it onto the
subspace, what I mean is, I
want to find some vector in
the subspace such that the
difference between v and that
point in the subspace is
orthogonal to the
subspace itself.
In other words, it's the same
idea as we used before for
this over-used picture.
Which I keep looking at.
Here, the subspace that I'm
looking at is just the
subspace of vectors
colinear with u.
And what I'm trying to do here
is to find, from v I'm trying
to drop a perpendicular to this
subspace, which is just a
straight line.
In general, what I'm trying
to do is, I have an
n-dimensional subspace.
We can sort of visualize a
two-dimensional subspace if
you think of this in
three dimensions.
And think of replacing u
with some space, some
two-dimensional space, which
is going through 0.
And now I have this vector,
v, which is
outside of that plane.
And what I'm trying to do here
is to drop a perpendicular
from v onto that subspace.
The projection is where that
perpendicular lands.
So, in other words, v, minus the
projection, is this v perp
we're talking about.
And what I want to do is exactly
the same thing that we
did before with the
one-dimensional projection theorem.
And that's what we're
going to do.
And it works.
And it isn't really any more
complicated, except for notation.
So the theorem says, assume
you have this orthonormal
basis for this subspace.
And then you take any old v in
the entire vector space.
This can be an infinite
dimensional vector space or
anything else.
And what we really want it to
be is some element in L2,
which is some
infinite-dimensional element.
It says there's a unique
projection in the subspace s.
And it's given by the inner
product of v with each of
those basis vectors.
That inner product,
times v sub j.
For the case of a
one-dimensional vector, you
take the sum out and that
was exactly the
projection we had before.
Now we just have the
multi-dimensional projection.
And it has a property that v
is equal to this projection
plus the orthogonal thing.
And the orthogonal thing, the
inner product of that with s
equal to 0 for all s
in the subspace.
In other words, it's just what
we got in this picture we were
just trying to construct, of
a two-dimensional plane.
You drop a perpendicular
two-dimensional plane.
And when I drop a perpendicular
to a
two-dimensional plane, and I
take any old vector in this
two-dimensional plane,
we still have the
perpendicularity.
In other words, you have the
notion of this vector being
perpendicular to a plane if it's
perpendicular whichever
way you look at it.
Let me outline the
proof of this.
Actually, it's pretty much
a complete proof.
But with a couple small
details left out.
We're going to start out the
same way I did before.
Namely, I don't know how
to choose this vector.
But I know I want to choose
it to be in this subspace.
And any element in this
subspace is a linear
combination of these
p sub i's.
So this is just a generic
element in s.
And I want to find out what
element I have to use.
I want to find the conditions
on these coefficients here
such that v minus the projection
-- in other words,
this v perp, as we've been
calling it -- is orthogonal to
each phi sub i.
Now, if it's orthogonal to
each phi sub i, it's also
orthogonal to each linear
combination
of the phi sub i's.
So in fact, that solved
our problem for us.
So what I want to do is, I want
to set 0 equal to v minus
this projection.
Where I don't yet know how to
make the projection, because I
don't know what the
alpha sub i's are.
But I'm trying to choose these
so that this, minus the
projection, the inner product of
that with phi j is equal to
0 for every j.
This inner product here is equal
to the inner product of
v with phi sub j.
I have this difference here,
so the inner product is the
inner product of v with phi sub
j minus the inner product
of this with phi sub j.
Let me write that here.
v minus sum alpha i phi sub i
comma phi sub j is equal to v
phi sub j minus summation
of i alpha i t sub i.
phi sub j.
Which is equal to this.
All of these terms are 0 except
where j is equal to i.
Where i is equal to j.
So, alpha sub j has to be equal
to the inner product of
v with this basis vector here.
And, therefore, this projection
is equal, which we
said was sum of alpha i phi sub
i, that's really the sum
of v phi sub j, this inner
product, times p sub j,
Now, if you really use your
imagination and you really
think hard about the formula we
were using for the Fourier
series coefficients, was
really the same formula
without the normalization
in it.
It's simplified by being already
normalized for us.
We don't have that 1 over t in
here, which we had in the
Fourier series because
now we've gone
to orthonormal functions.
So, in fact that sort of
proves the theorem.
If we express v as some linear
combination of these
orthonormal vectors, then if I
take the norm squared of v,
this is something we've done
many times already.
I just express the norm squared,
just by expanding
this the sum of -- well, here
I've done it this way, so
let's do it this way again.
When I take the inner product
of v with all of these terms
here, I get the sum of alpha
sub j complex conjugated,
times the inner product
of v with phi sub j.
But the inner product of v with
phi sub j is just alpha
sub j times 1.
So it's a sum of alpha
sub j squared.
OK, this is this energy
relationship we've
been using all along.
We've been using it for
the Fourier series.
everything we've been doing.
It's just a special case of
this relationship here, in
this n-dimensional projection,
except that there we were
dealing with infinite dimensions
and here we're
dealing with finite
dimensions.
But it's the same formula, and
you'll see how it generalizes
in a little bit.
We still have the Pythagorean
theorem, which in this case
says that the norm squared of
vector v is equal to the norm
squared of a projection, plus
the norm squared of the
perpendicular part.
In other words, when I start
to represent this vector
outside of the space by a vector
inside the space, by
this projection, I wind
up with two things.
I wind up both with the part
that's outside of the space
entirely, and is orthogonal to
the space, plus the part which
is in the space.
And each of those has a certain
amount of energy.
When I expand this by this
relationship here --
I'm not doing that yet -- what
I'm doing here is what's
called a norm bound.
Which says both of these
terms are non-negative.
This term is non-negative in
particular, and therefore the
difference between this and this
is always positive, or
non-negative.
Which says that 0 has to be less
than or equal to this,
because it's non-negative.
And this has to be less than or
equal to the norm of v. In
other words, the projection
always has less energy then
the vector itself.
Which is not very surprising.
So the norm bound
is no big deal.
When I substitute this for the
actual value, what I get is
the sum j equals 1 to n of the
norm of the inner product of
v, with each one of these
basis vectors, magnitude
squared, that's less than or
equal to the energy in v. In
other words, if we start to
expand, as n gets bigger and
bigger, and we look at these
terms, we take these inner
products, square them.
No matter how many terms I take
here, the sum is always
less than or equal to the energy
in v. That's called
Bessel's inequality, and it's a
nice, straightforward thing.
And finally, the last
of these things --
well, I'll use the other
one if I need it.
The last is this thing
called the mean
square error property.
It says that if you take the
difference between the vector
and its projection onto this
space, this is less than or
equal to the difference between
the vector and the
other s in the space.
Any other --
I can always represent v as
being equal to this plus the
orthogonal component.
So I wind up with a sum
here of two terms.
One is the difference between
-- well, it's the --
it's the length squared
of the projection.
Write it out.
v minus v s -- let me write this
term out. v minus s is
equal to v, the projection, plus
v perpendicular to the
subspace s minus
this vector s.
This is perpendicular to this
and this, so -- ah,
to hell with it.
Excuse my language.
I mean, this is proven
in the notes.
I'm not going to go through it
now because I want to finish
these other things.
I don't want to play
around with it.
We left something out of the
n-dimensional projection theorem.
How do you find an orthonormal
basis to start with?
And there's this neat thing
called Gram-Schmidt, which I
suspect most of you have
seen before also.
Which is pretty simple
now in terms of
the projection theorem.
Gram-Schmidt is really a
bootstrap operation starting
with the one-dimensional
projection theorem, working
your way up to larger and
larger dimensions.
And each case winding up with an
orthonormal basis for what
you started with.
Let's see how that happens.
I start out with a basis for
an inner product subspace.
So, s1 up to s sub n
as a basis for this
inner product space.
First thing I do is, I
start out with s1.
I find the normalized
version of s1.
I call that phi 1.
So phi 1 is now an orthonormal
basis for the subspace whose
basis is just phi 1 itself.
phi 1 is the basis for the
subspace of all linear
combinations of s1.
So it's just a straight
line in space.
The next thing I do
is, I take s2.
I find the projection of
s2 on this subspace s1.
I can do that.
So I find a part which
is colinear with s1.
I find the part which
is orthogonal.
I take the orthogonal
part, and that's
orthogonal, to phi 1.
And I normalize it.
So I then have two vectors, phi
1 and phi 2, which span
the space of functions
of linear
combinations of s1 and s2.
And I call that subspace
S2, capital S2.
And then I go on.
So, given any orthonormal basis,
phi 1 up to phi sub k
of the subspace s k generated
by s1 to s k, I'm going to
project s k plus 1 onto this
subspace s sub k, and then I'm
going to normalize it.
And by going through this
procedure, I can in fact find
an orthonormal basis to any set
of vectors that I want to,
to any subspace that
I want to.
Why is this important, is this
something you want to do?
Well, it's something you can
program a computer to do
almost trivially.
But that's not why
we want it here.
The thing we want it here is to
say that there's no reason
to deal with bases other
than orthonormal bases.
We can generate orthonormal
bases easily.
The projection theorem now is
valid for any n-dimensional
space because for any
n-dimensional space we can
form this basis that we want.
Let me just go on and finish
this, so we can start dealing
with channels next time.
So far, the projection
theorem is just for
finite dimensional vectors.
We want to now extend it to
infinite dimensional vectors.
To accountably infinite
set of vectors.
So I'm given any orthogonal set
of functions, status sub
i, we can first generate
orthonormal functions as phi
sub i, which are normalized.
And that's old stuff.
I can now think of doing the
same thing that we did before.
Namely, starting out, taking any
old vector I want to, and
projecting it first on
to the subspace with
only phi 1 in it.
Then the subspace generated by
phi 1 and phi 2, then the
subspace generated by phi 1, phi
2 and phi 3, and so forth.
When I do that successively,
which is successive
approximations in a Fourier
expansion, or in any
orthonormal expansion, what I'm
going to wind up with is
the following theorem that says,
let phi sub m be a set
of orthonormal functions.
Let v be any L2 vector.
Then there exists an L2 vector,
u, such that v minus u
is orthogonal to
each phi sub n.
In other words, this is the
projection theorem, carried on
as n goes to infinity.
But I can't quite state it
in the way I did before.
I need a limit in here.
Which says the limit as n goes
to infinity of u, namely what
is now going to be this
projection, minus this term
here, which is the term
in the subspace of
these orthonormal functions.
This difference goes to zero.
What does this say?
It doesn't say that I can take
any function, v, and expand it
in an orthonormal expansion.
I couldn't say that, because I
have nothing to know whether
this arbitrary orthonormal
expansion I started with
actually spans L2 or not.
And without knowing that,
I can't state a
theorem like this.
But what the theorem does say
is, you take any orthonormal
expansion you want to.
Like the Fourier series, which
only spans functions which are
time limited.
I take an arbitrary function.
I expand them in this
Fourier series.
And, bingo, what I get is a
function u, which is the part
of v, which is within these time
limits and what's left
over, which is orthogonal, is
the stuff outside of those
time limits.
So this is the theorem that says
that in fact you can --
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: It's similar
to Plancherel.
Plancherel is done for the
Fourier integral, and in
Plancherel you need this limit
in the mean on both sides.
Here we're just dealing
with a series.
I mean, we still have a limit in
the mean sort of thing, but
we have a weaker theorem in
the sense that we're not
asserting that this orthonormal
series actually
spans all of L2.
I mean, we found a couple of
orthonormal expansions
that do span L2.
So it's lacking in that.
OK, going to stop there.